my name is Jen Brallier
and I am here today with Charlotte Stewart
and who did you play on Little House
I was Miss Beadle
the school teacher
and the wonderful school teacher
you were wonderful really
you are wonderful
but you are wonderful in Little House
so how many seasons did you do
I was on the first four
the first actually
starting from about the second episode
um until the
until Amanzo and his sister moved to town
yeah and then you kind of exit her
yes you exited
you got married
got married I got married to the pink farmer yes
and that episode of Nelly and Luke ha ha
that one will live on forever in my memory
cause that one was so funny
but did you have a
did you guys have a fun time recording that episode
we did and especially with Missus Olsen
um because Nelly elopes with Luke
who's the pig farmer's son
and missus Olsen wants none of it
she says unmarry them and so
and they were married
they got married
they got they actually got married yeah and
and then he was like
I don't know how to unmarry this
and it was Wild
Nelly actually was married before festival
they were in the hotel
they were literally about to
you know do it ha ha ha ha
yeah they were
she had her hair in roller
yeah you know
she was ready to go to bed mmm hmm
wild not wild
so what did you love most about your character
oh well I like that she was a real person
Miss Beadle was a real person
she taught
Laura Ingalls
and she's written
you can read about her in the books
um my godmother was a teacher
in a one room school room in Mendocino
California which is a very small town
wow so I just like
I felt like I was doing honor to my godmother
my mother was a teacher
wow um so I I
no I could never be a teacher
I was a travel student
right that they were people that were close to me in the family that
yeah I think I was doing it for them
yeah and you
and you loved it
oh I love playing it
I loved acting
yeah you know
I had been acting since I got my first part when I was 19
wow with and was that bonanza
what was your first part
was the Loretta Young show
okay and that was about 1961
um I was about nineteen
so yeah I started real early
and I did all of those
with Westerns
the bananas and
Gunsmoke Medical Center FBI
my three sons
that's your father
you know and you were just having the time of your life
doing all that
I thought it was a dream
was it a dream come true for you
yeah well you know
I never really thought about it
when I was growing up
I didn't say
I wanna act yeah
but I was a very bad student in high school
and I wasn't gonna be able to go to college
wow because all my friends were going to Yale and Harvard and
I saw an advertisement on the back of teen magazine
and it was for the Passagena Playhouse
the State Theater California
and it was Earl Hall
and it was a former student there
and so I thought
I can do that
so I sent away for an application
wow and I was accepted
and then I told my mother and she said
well we'll see about this
and we drove to Pasadena and she was very impressed wow
I mean it's a seven story building
it's got six theaters in it
I would have to live in a dormitory
wow so it I mean
it was everything that she wished for me
get away from UVA City
live in a dormitory
do something new
yeah she had no idea what it to do
right and um
and that's how it started
and I got my first job at 19 on the Loretta Young show wow
with already young
perfect love
that sounds so good
so out of all the episodes
cause you were in four seasons
what was your favorite episode to film
maybe not what was your favorite episode
like overall or both
what was your favorite episode that like
sticks in your memory when you think about Little House
and your time on Little House of life
I loved filming that episode
that was so much fun
okay it's gotta be when Miss Fetal marries pig farmer
and you know
if they actually gave this beetle a whole episode
yeah you did
you had your own special little moment exactly
and now you deserved it
Allison did too
now Nelly meets the pig farmer's son Luke
and falls in love with him
and you know
it's a whole story about how she she
she gets to marry Luke
and then Missus Olsen comes and you know
blows it all apart
so it's fun to do
I bet that was a fun time
and also because the actor that played my husband
my boyfriend on the show um
the actor that
that played the Pig Farmer
was the student at the passing in the playhouse when I was there
so we had known each other since we were 17
that's why your chemistry works
it was great
we were best friends for years
and here it is
you know he gets to play my husband
you know so it was wonderful
that is so sweet
everyone on the cast
who are you closest to on and offset
who did you last time when you shot oh no
that missus Olsen
really yes she was my
she was my friend on the set
and we used to go to
um retreats together
we went to you know
spas for the weekend and all
yeah she was um
she was one of my best friends
she seems she I
I wish I could have known her
she seems like she was a wonderful lady
she was wonderful yeah
and she was outrageous on the show
four years was it
about four years of you
of you filming um
what is one of your favorite memories of Michael Landon
I know we've talked some about your audition um
overall but and
and how you got the part to begin with
but do you have a specific favorite memory with Michael um
first of all
he's one of the best directors I've ever worked with
he's a family man and what he
what he like to do was shoot in a way
so that we were done by 6 o'clock at night
I was on all these shows where they would work until midnight
bring us in at six in the morning
I don't know how crews even had family lives
but Michael had
Michael was family man
so he shot very economically
and I love that so I
I enjoyed working with him
but I'll tell you
my best friend on the show is Victor French
oh Mister Edwards
yes we became such good friends
and I think I
I spent more time with Victor than anybody really yeah
that's beautiful
I my husband and I just started rewatching highway to heaven
oh he's never seen it
Jake never seen highway to heaven
and I was like
we've gotta watch highway to heaven
it is so good
and there's several seasons of it
and you and I was in highway to heaven too
yes you were
you were in a few episodes
or one or two right
I was in a double episode
double episode
the two parter wow
there you go
and Victor French and Michael Landon
they just worked so well together
they did and it's super
super cool that they were able to carry on working together
after a little house and
yeah what are
what are you up to now
because I know the 50th is coming up
it's yeah and
are you gonna be there
oh yes I've already
she's gonna be there
we're gonna be in Simi Valley
California in March
our 50th anniversary
it's going to be huge just here
there's gonna be so many things for guests to do
and I think it's gonna be
like a three day event
I'm not sure
I hear it's gonna be huge
yeah I don't know the specifics of it
but there's there's uh
places you could go online
and find information
yeah so you're gonna be there
I'm gonna be there
and you're also doing some smaller events
is there anything else
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
I'm just telling you what you're doing ha ha
um I don't know
I just go everywhere
wherever they
tell me to go
and go yeah so
you're gonna be around this
so people can come and see you
and meet you
come meet Miss Beetle
and she has these little
she cute bag
she has these cute
little bags she makes
they're adorable
and come over here quick
quick come over here
baby Grace featuring
this is baby Grace
Louis Wendy hello
hello everyone
there's my face on the bag
perfect thank you
and I do all the characters from Little House on the Prairie on my tote bags
so cute and I also
I also raise money for a hospital in Napa cause I'm a cancer survivor and uh
there's a program at the Napa
uh hospital where they do recovery for breast cancer patients
so it's called Bosom Buddies
oh that's so good right
that's so clever
ever since I moved in Napa
I've been raising money from them
oh that's awesome
so are you on any social media at all
no you're nowhere I do
do you have a website or anything
nope nope nobody
so if you're looking for
you have to come to an event
just like Pam
Pam has no social media either
I'm telling everybody I'm like
you're just gonna have to come to the event and see them
I'm too busy already
you don't have time to do that
you don't have time to do that stuff
thank you so much
you're so welcome
you're so nice to meet you
you're so nice to meet and chat
and maybe I'll see you at the 50th
it's looking like I will
absolutely it's gonna be a fun time okay
and you guys need to come by and see this beetle soon
thank you so much thank you